the point is that these events didn't
end in the past right the issue is that
these events that happened centuries ago
decades ago
continue to live on today like their
impacts continue to be felt
today on chalk radio we're exploring
transitional and reparative justice
and how seeking expertise from
everywhere
might lead to better understanding
the process of record of justice is
about well how do we address that how do
we address what is today and how do we
seek justice for what's happened in the
past as it means towards addressing
these challenges today and being able to
move forward from them being able to
move on to something else
i'm your host sarah hansen
my guest today is professor amaedo
an assistant professor of anthropology
and african studies at mit
you may remember amma from her episode
on chalk radio back in season one we're
sitting down with her again
this time to discuss her course called
reparations for slavery and colonization
contemporary movements for justice
the inspiration for the course came in
part from the black lives matter
protests that took place around the
world in 2020
what was expressed during these protests
whether in the u.s or in europe where i
have a lot of friends and collaborators
and so i was kind of hearing echoes from
both sides of the atlantic
was kind of a framing of contemporary
racial
injustice racial discrimination racism
as a legacy of slavery and colonialism
right and so thinking about police
violence but also thinking about
housing discrimination and also thinking
about the collections that are held in
european or american museums thinking
about
so many aspects of our lives today and
recognizing that so many of the
disparities and the injustices that were
brought to the surface through these
protests right and that we're surrounded
by at all times
have a historical origin this is what
was so powerful
in these protests around the world was
that they were saying there's no dealing
with
what we recognize is a problem today
without dealing or talking about what
happened in the past right and so
this class was meant to take that
seriously and to say well how what are
the models for that because reparations
has been
and continues to be an incendiary topic
is still seen as somewhat controversial
and i think part of that stems from
partial understanding about what is
meant by reparations and kind of a
knee-jerk reaction to
to the idea of what reparations is
if you've been on any social media site
recently ama's statement likely feels
true to you there do seem to be strong
reactions to the idea of what
reparations are
i asked amma how she defines or
conceptualizes reparations
it's about establishing the record the
historical record or redressing the
historical record
so that the harms that have been done
can be named and then thinking about
well what does what my justice look like
this one thing to learn from events that
have happened in the past it's another
to try to
learn from what's happening in the
moment and put that in conversation of
course with what's happened in the past
but to to document to learn and
interrogate what's happening as it's
happening was super exciting and it was
the prospect of engaging students in
that process
to me was really really powerful as an
instructor
ama's interest in justice and
anthropology is something that stems
from her past
she shared how growing up across western
and southern africa and the united
states shaped her understanding of what
it means to be black and african in the
world
so i was born in the u.s my parents were
in graduate school in the u.s from togo
and so i had an american passport from
birth and i was the only one in my
family to have an american passport and
among my friends you know we're in togo
and i remember you know as young as i
don't know five or six feeling that
having this american passport was really
special and that somehow it made me
better quote unquote it doesn't feel
great to admit that but that's the truth
of it i felt like somehow especially
because i had this american passport
why does a six-year-old have that kind
of consciousness right like where does
that come from there was always a sense
that real life happened elsewhere that
real life was happening in the u.s i
realized was happening in europe and all
these other places and the goal and that
the idea was always to leave
you know and then race comes into it
when i started paying attention to skin
bleaching or even this hair
straightening these were things that i
was noticing in my environment whether
in togo it was congolese music videos we
we listened to a lot of music from the
congo at the time and so you i started
noticing there was a moment where you'd
start noticing men and women who
bleached their skin and so you could see
the signs and then this question about
why why is that a thing
and after college i was in zambia for a
few years and
one day i tried to actually make an
experiment of it and i was on the
minibus and i was looking out the window
and i was like let me count how many
women that i see
actually skin bleach or have evidence of
skin bleaching and it was three out of
four you know just during this little
ride
so you know this question about what
does lighter skin mean why do people put
themselves through this given you know
the health effects and so on questions
about skin color about race about one's
place in the world all these things are
part of for me the question of
africanness in the world
alma understands that students too bring
their personal histories into the
classroom
she tries to create a space for sharing
perspectives and honoring individual
experiences
and when discussing concepts like
reparations it becomes all the more
important to do this
i think it's really about
opening up space for
for sharing for conversation and
honoring all the participants
contributions right and showing that
we're we're building this thing together
as we go and learning together
one thing that's evolved for me over the
course of the semester even was just
trying to shift from talking about
reparations to talking about repetitive
justice i think there are associations
that are made with the word reparations
and that can prompt knee-jerk reactions
i think that emphasizing the justice
side of it and the perceptual side of it
by saying repetitive justice
opens up a little bit of space but
reparations or report of justice i think
can be or should be part of a
transitional justice mechanism which is
really just
meant to address
widespread or large-scale human rights
violations
reproductive justice might be one of the
many things that go into seeking justice
for
abuses of violations that happen at a
large scale where you can't deal with
the harms that were done to people
individually
while material compensation is one of
the most common examples of reparations
explained that reparative justice isn't
just limited to that
things such as amending our historical
records and honoring the people who've
been disenfranchised by colonization and
racial inequity are just as important
you can have material reparations
in the form of money or land or other
forms of resources and then also
symbolic reparations that are part of
ideally part of a healing process a
process of acknowledging that these
harms were made that they had
significant impacts and that moving
forward requires
actually
addressing what's happened in past
because oftentimes this is a critique
that's brought forward well why do you
want to reopen old wounds this is just
going to stoke tension it's going to
still conflict this is only going you
know just it happened a long time ago
people today are not responsible for
what was done centuries ago et cetera et
cetera
but the point is that these events
didn't end in the past right the issue
is that these events that happened
centuries ago decades ago
continue to live on today like their
impacts continue to be felt whether it's
at the level of individual bodies or if
it's at the level of societies or in the
landscape in the literal land right the
legacies of colonialism in various parts
of the world is held in the actual land
are held in people's bodies physically
psychologically not to mention the
structural disadvantage that the
descendants of of enslaved people or
formerly colonized people continue to
face so these issues are not
past there's nothing that's passed about
them they're very much on the present
tense and so the process of record of
justice is about well how do we address
that how do we address what is today and
how do we seek justice for what's
happened in the past as it means towards
addressing these challenges today and
being able to move forward from them
being able to move on to something else
that's where the transitional justice
angle or kind of frame comes in or the
language let's say right like if we
think about this as a transition towards
something
better
repetitive justice
needs to be part of that
one of the main assignments students
work on in the course is creating a case
study documenting what it takes to work
towards reparative justice and what
challenges arise along the way
by compiling these studies ama is
building up an archive within her lab
the african futures action lab which she
co-founded with her colleague liliane o
mubie
the goal of the lab is to support
unfolding movements for reparative
justice across europe africa and the
americas
amis course seeks to combine the
expertise of different activist groups
one from algeria and one in belgium with
those of guest speakers by bringing them
together for discussions
these dialogues are shared in the
classroom where students can discuss
them and apply them to their case
studies
essentially the model for the class
comes from the afa lab the african
futures action lab kind of what's at the
core of our mission which is to bring
together different or to connect
different forms of expertise around
these questions right recognizing that
you have all these people who hold a lot
of knowledge and expertise relevant to
these struggles for justice and for
racial justice and reproductive justice
but who are necessarily in conversation
with one another so how do we facilitate
these exchanges right and so bringing
that in conversation with the classroom
and saying how can we not only bring
these different folks in conversation
with one another but how can we have
that be part of the learning experience
for students
in the case of the algeria group it was
made up of three
scholars and activists who
are algerian they approached us because
they were interested in exploring what
had been done the kinds of claims that
had been brought against the french
state for
colonial violence broadly and then
specifically also for nuclear tests that
were conducted in algeria in the sahara
after independence
the second group was already organized
as a civil society organization so it
was a collective of afro-descended
belgian people that was formed in
response to a commission that was set up
by the belgian state this summer to
examine belgium's colonial past in the
congo burundi in rwanda
one of the speakers that we brought in
was anna moyo kupeta who is the
executive director of the center for the
study of violence and reconciliation in
south africa and she's a transitional
justice expert
and a lawyer and long-time activist she
came in to speak with the belgian group
in particular about how civil society
can
hold accountable the state commission
right the role that the civil society
can play in transitional justice
processes and it was a super interesting
conversation a bit intimidating i think
in the sense that she really laid out to
us
how this is work that unfolds over the
course of years right like the kind of
the lobbying and the advocacy work and
the
sentinel work that civil society
organizations have to do to hold state
entities accountable and so it made it
really concrete for the group that could
then say okay what are we able to do
given the time and the resources that we
have
it was really important for us to have
throughout this process have voices that
are coming from different directions so
to have an expert from south africa
inform the process in belgium for
instance was really important to us
right because again you know it was we
think about the many layers of
intervention at this course this or the
work that we're doing with the lab is
meant to do to accomplish it's also to
highlight the fact that expertise
resides everywhere and it's not just a
north-south kind of direction for the
transfer of knowledge information but
you know south south south north all of
it
expertise resides everywhere
that's a powerful idea
and it's one that shaped how ama
designed the course
as part of the course she shared guest
speakers videos on the mit open
courseware youtube channel
she invited learners from around the
world to share their expertise questions
and perspectives in the comments
the idea was that these comments could
then be brought back into the classroom
and then we could in the classroom
engage them and sort of be in
conversation with those comments and
then that i could then bring it back
how did it actually unfold so there were
a lot of comments that that felt like
knee-jerk reactions to reparations being
in the title rather than the actual
content of the videos
that was different from what we had
envisioned and so i think we had less
material to work with in terms of the
comments of the videos that could be
brought into the classroom than what we
had imagined but still it was very
interesting and generative to bring back
the comments that we did get into the
classroom we had some really nice
discussions with students because it
reminded us again that these issues that
we're dealing with in the class are
unfolding live
amma later explained to me that in
hindsight it might have been helpful to
provide more connective tissue for the
youtube audience
after all students attending the mit
class had access to readings and other
course materials to provide context and
to frame the discussion around
reparations
youtube learners didn't have those
materials
to fix that amma is currently working on
sharing all of her teaching materials
from the course on our mit open
courseware website
i found ama's reflections interesting
so i asked her to share three tips for
other educators who might want to try
opening their classrooms through public
forums
[Music]
i think having some degree of awareness
of how your topic
is seen or will land or kind of what it
means out in the world by sort of
remembering kind of what does this
mean to people outside of that setting
right because that has implications for
the kinds of comments that you might get
and therefore how you might frame you
know how you share what you share how
you respond and so on
having a great team i think i think it's
absolutely a team effort i think working
with folks who are again back to the
question of expertise right who are
coming in with knowledge that we can't
have all the knowledge in ourselves so
you all brought in
knowledge about these educational
platforms that open up onto the world
and what it takes to
make that possible technically and also
in terms of the the nature of the
engagement right what we can expect how
to plan for that all that and all of it
really um having it be a team effort and
taking stock ahead of time of the range
of expertise that's needed to do this
both technically content wise and and
conceptually
and then the third tip i think it's not
to be afraid to like to experiment i
think you know we at the a few months
ago were just like oh god how's this
gonna work out right like we had the
sense i think we all felt that this was
a good idea and i still think it's a
good idea and i really i really hope to
see it like in the full-blown version of
kind of the vision because i really
still believe in the idea i still
believe in the model i'm grateful to you
all for your willingness also to
experiment and i think that that's
something that we were like all right
let's just try it let's just try it and
let's see what works and i think we
really didn't manage to
nothing went massively wrong you know
and actually and i think some things
actually went a lot actually went right
and i certainly learned a lot from it
and i and you know seeing what my
students produce at the end of it i
think they got a lot from it the
activists at the end were very
grateful and like also inspired by the
process so i think it was a success in
many ways so i think being willing to to
take risks and to experiment and to
recognize that it's not going to be
perfect at the first pass
this is part of learning right it's
about making mistakes and figuring it
out as you go
so you can do it better next time
this is a philosophy that amma is truly
living out
she shared some things she hopes to
learn from other educators to improve
how teaching and learning unfold in her
classroom
i would love to learn more about how
folks
talk about a topic that's considered
controversial incendiary in a way that
draws people in that both does justice
to the seriousness of it and that's kind
of uncompromising in the sense in terms
of you know its sense of what needs to
be done and the importance of it without
being alienating right how do you draw
folks in without compromising on the
reality or kind of your sense of why
this matters and what it is
how do you draw people in without
compromising on that
and then
relatedly we can underestimate the
challenges of talking or interacting
across areas of practice and disciplines
and and expertise like we don't we don't
speak the same language we don't think
in the same terms and so how folks have
navigated that because
building relationships takes time so how
do you foster a space where
folks can interact meaningfully when
they don't have very much time to spend
together
this idea of bringing people from
different practices and disciplines
together to find expertise everywhere is
part of what makes professor edo's
course so valuable
it creates a wealth of perspectives that
are actively reshaping how we view the
conversation on race justice and equity
around the globe
if you're interested in adding your
expertise or to learn from others you
can find ama's videos on our mit open
courseware youtube site you'll soon find
her teaching materials on our mit
opencourseware website as well
you can find ama's lab online at
www.africanfutures.mit.edu
thank you so much for listening
until next time signing off from
cambridge massachusetts i'm your host
sarah hansen from mit open courseware
chalk radio's producers include myself
fred pache and dave lashansky
our scriptwriters are nidhish astrid and
aubry
show notes for this episode were written
by peter chipman
and amaedo's course materials are shared
on our ocw website by rhys jenkins
we're funded by mit open learning and
supporters like you